[Musique]
alors peut-être que certains d'entre
vous
m'ont connu en tant que Miss France
d'autres peut-être en tant que chanteuse
ou encore comédienne
ou peut-être animatrice télé ou
peut-être entrepreneuse ou peut-être que
vous ne connaissez pas du tout et ça va
très bien aussi comme ça
je dis ça évidemment ça fait beaucoup de
choses très différentes mais toutes ces
activités
m'ont permis
d'avoir l'habitude de parler en public
normalement pour faire de la promo sur
des plateaux de télé
des émissions de radio des supports très
différents
ou sinon quand je présente une émission
de télé j'ai des fiches j'ai un
prompteur mais je dois vous dire que ce
soir
et ben tous mes repères
ne sont pas là je suis seule face à vous
pas de fiches pas de prompteur rien du
tout je suis juste seul face à vous et
je dois vous parler de ma vie
et c'est pas facile
il y a un peu plus de 20 ans
25 ans exactement parce que j'ai compté
dans le taxi en arrivant je suis devenue
Miss France 1999 Miss France ça veut
dire que en deux heures de temps en deux
heures d'émission de télé 2 heures ça
passe comme ça c'est hyper rapide en
deux heures je suis passée de l'anonymat
le plus total à l'exposition la plus
totale
j'avais 18 ans
et je n'étais pas prête pas du tout
je suis devenue très entouré j'avais
tout un tas de gens autour de moi
mais je ne m'appelais plus Mareva
tout le monde m'appelait Miss France
j'étais sous les projecteurs
et sous les projecteurs je peux vous
affirmer que les gens ne me regardaient
plus du tout de la même façon
d'un seul coup j'étais fantastique
j'étais magnifique j'étais bref j'avais
des qualités extraordinaires
c'est flatteur
sauf que deux heures avant
pas du tout j'étais pas regardé comme ça
et pendant les 18 années qui avaient
précédé non plus
donc du haut de mes 18 ans je me suis
dit waouh sous les projecteurs il y a
quand même quelque chose qui est pas
tout à fait normal et qui est un peu
déroutant
j'étais donc très entouré
mais je me sentais très seule
très seule parce que perdu n'ayant pas
l'école pas les clés et ne sachant pas
comment faire
alors j'ai fait du mieux que j'ai pu et
comme j'ai pu quand je vous dis très
entouré j'étais vraiment très entouré
garde du corps attaché de presse
maquilleuse coiffeuse escort par la
police municipale quand je me déplaçais
un truc de fou
mais je me sentais seul quand même c'est
un truc de dingue
et même que je n'avais pas d'appartement
parce que je venais d'arriver à Paris un
palace parisien m'avait prêté sa suite
présidentielle sublime
et ben mon attaché de presse avait
décidé de squatter mon salon
donc même là je n'étais pas seul je
pense qu'elle aimait bien la suite mais
en tout cas elle était là avec moi 24
heures sur 24 et tous les matins elle
veillait à ce que je sois parfaite
elle me disait ce qu'il fallait que je
dise
ce qu'il fallait pas que je dise comment
il fallait que je me comporte bref
j'avais un espèce de brief parce que je
devais être parfait l'image de Miss
France Miss France
c'est comme si elle n'avait pas
d'émotion
c'est comme si elle avait pas de désir
elle a pas de week-end pas de jours
férié bon j'avais 18 ans donc ça va mais
c'est une enveloppe un personnage et on
entend on attend pardon beaucoup de
cette image de Miss France
alors bon encore une fois je faisais
comme je pouvais mais c'était très
difficile
les quelques années qui ont suivi Miss
France
c'était pas facile non plus
j'avais envie de faire de la télé du
cinéma
des films des téléfilms
j'avais envie d'abord accès à un milieu
artistique culturel pour ça il fallait
que je fasse mes preuves donc j'ai dû
passer des castings
et quand je rentrais dans une salle de
casting j'ouvrais la porte
je me retrouvais face à un directeur ou
une directrice une directrice de casting
et je lisais le mépris total sur leur
visage
le mépris total à mon égard
j'avais pas encore dit bonjour j'avais
pas encore fait une scène j'avais rien
fait
et je me disais waouh ça va être dur
mais je m'accrochais et j'y allais quand
même c'est bon maintenant que je suis là
on y va
et ça me rappelle
une expérience assez particulière une
fois un metteur en scène de théâtre
m'avait choisi pour jouer sa pièce de
théâtre un théâtre parisien magnifique
on en était aux répétitions dans le
théâtre avec les autres comédiens
c'était super
au bout de quelques jours
la comédienne principale la tête
d'affiche comme on dit est entrée dans
le théâtre
elle est allée sur le plateau
directement voir le metteur en scène
et elle lui a dit c'est elle ou moi
elle c'était moi
je vous laisse imaginer
l'ambiance générale sur le plateau
moi ça m'a fait du mal
ça m'a vexé ça m'a blessé
et les autres étaient très embarrassés
maintenant cette comédienne on s'était
pas dit bonjour on s'était jamais
rencontrés de notre vie on ne se
connaissait absolument pas elle ne
m'avait pas vu jouer mais
elle avait
l'image de mon image en tête c'est à
dire
qu'elle savait ce que je représentais
mais elle ne savait pas qui j'étais
des expériences comme ça j'en ai eu
plein vous me direz il faut faire ses
preuves j'imagine que vous aussi dans
des domaines totalement différents vous
êtes peut-être retrouvé parfois
confronté à des situations vous n'avez
pas été pris dans un boulot ou autre
chose et vous avez envie de hurler en
vous disant en disant mais je peux le
faire mais je sais le faire mais
donnez-moi ma chance je vais y arriver
il faut du temps
alors le temps je l'ai pris le temps est
passé je mets je me suis toujours
accroché je me disais mais j'ai des
valeurs je sais qui je suis je sais d'où
je viens et je continuerai
à cette époque quelqu'un qui m'était
très cher me répétait cette phrase de
René Char impose ta chance
sert ton bonheur et va vers ton risque à
te regarder il s'habitueront
au début
ça me paraissait un peu abstrait
et au fil du temps
cette phrase
n'a fait que résonner en moi
et je me suis dit
va vers ton risque à te regarder il
s'habitueront elle était là ma liberté
elle était là ma liberté continuer
d'imposer mes choix continuer d'imposer
qui j'étais ma double culture et ma
différence
ce qui est pas toujours facile
parce que quand on arrive dans une
grande ville et qu'on vient d'un autre
pays peut-être que vous aussi vous
n'êtes pas parisien moi non plus je suis
pas parisienne
c'est difficile d'apprendre des codes
des habitudes une façon de faire bref je
me suis dit je m'accroche j'y vais j'ai
rencontré des personnes fantastiques
évidemment je n'ai pas eu que des
situations chaotiques j'ai fait des
collaborations extraordinaires
et pendant très très longtemps j'ai fait
des émissions de télé pendant je sais
pas à 18 ou 20 ans sur toutes les
chaînes confondues des émissions de de
mode de musique de déco tout un tas de
choses que j'ai adoré faire
j'ai fait des collaborations
extraordinaires en musique un groupe que
j'aille rejoint qui s'appelle nouvelle
vague j'ai fait des concerts avec eux
dans le monde entier détourner aux
Etats-Unis en Australie au Brésil en
Chine toute l'Europe de l'Est l'Italie
la Grèce l'Angleterre l'Irlande bref je
suis allé partout avec un autre groupe
les Parisiennes j'ai fait les salles de
concerts les plus prestigieuses de
France j'ai fait un tas de choses
extraordinaire tout ça m'a pris beaucoup
de temps mais j'avais toujours en moi
cette différence je me sentais
différente toujours
et je me disais que c'était ma force en
fait d'être différente pardon parce que
je commençais ma vie un petit peu
bizarrement
alors ce que je viens de vous raconter
je l'appelle ma deuxième vie parce que
je ne suis pas né je n'ai pas agrandi à
Paris ma première vie
elle est à Tahiti je suis né et j'ai
grandi à Tahiti
alors pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
comment vous dire Tahiti c'est le bout
du bout du bout du monde
la Polynésie au milieu de l'océan
Pacifique c'est 23 heures de vol pour
arriver à Paris 23h de vol c'est
mettez-vous en situation un jour et une
nuit on part pas comme ça sur un coup de
tête on réfléchit à ce voyage
et à Tahiti en Polynésie tout est
différent
quand je vous dis tout tout le climat
la culture la nourriture les odeurs les
saveurs tout est différent et je suis
née et j'ai grandi là-bas et j'ai
toujours gardé en moi
cette culture
c'est qui je suis
toute ma famille est restée là-bas
encore aujourd'hui
et je chéris les moments que je passe
avec eux et au téléphone aussi parce que
évidemment je peux pas y aller très
souvent
et je chéris la différence entre ce qui
vide et ce que je vis
quand j'appelle ma grand-mère parfois
enfin souvent d'ailleurs j'appelle ma
grand-mère souvent mais parfois je lui
dis ah mamie j'ai fait ce soir et
diffuser une émission télé ça fait des
semaines où ça fait des jours entiers
que j'ai travaillé dessus c'est super tu
vas la regarder
et elle me dit
ce soir c'est quoi 21h à 21h c'est trop
tard mais je dors tu te rends pas compte
demain matin le manguier les manques que
tu adores il est plein à craquer il y a
le jardinier qui vient à 6h30 7h il faut
que je sois avec lui et tout et tout
donc mon émission c'est à dire tout le
stress que ça engendré pour moi de la
faire et tout le boulot que ça
représentait
passe à la trappe mais j'adore ces
moments-là parce que ça me fait
redescendre et ça me fait garder les
pieds sur terre
une fois j'appelle ma mère
et je lui dis Maman j'ai fait un sujet
qui va paraître la semaine prochaine
dans Paris Match 6 pages dans Paris
Match j'étais hyper fière de moi
ma mère elle me dit
Paris Match je crois qu'il va mettre
deux mois à arriver par bateau
mais bon ça fait quand même vachement
longtemps qu'on t'a pas vu dans la
presse locale
bon pour ma mère c'est beaucoup plus
important d'être dans la presse locale
que d'être dans Paris Match donc pareil
une fois de plus moi qui était excité de
cette séance photo ou du sujet qui
allait paraître fait que tout ça c'était
éphémère être sous les projecteurs dans
la lumière
pas plus tard que tout à l'heure dans le
taxi en arrivant j'ai eu ma mère et je
lui dis je vais faire une conférence une
conférence TED
il m'a dit c'est qui
j'ai dit Ted il dit mais c'est qui
t'aide je dis c'est un copain
bref et tout ça en fait dans le taxi ça
m'a enlevé le stress de faire cette
conférence TED je me suis dit après tout
pour moi le plus important c'est quand
même ma famille c'est quand même ce
qu'il pense ce qui reçoivent comme
information ils ont jamais vraiment
compris ce que je faisais ici à Paris
ils savent un peu plus ou moins mais il
n'y attache pas d'importance donc c'est
comme si j'avais toujours eu de vie ma
vie à Tahiti ma vie à Paris donc ma vie
de tahitienne et ma vie de
métropolitaine et pendant des années je
me suis dit mais quel projet je peux
mettre en oeuvre qu'est-ce que je peux
partager qui ressemble et qui fasse
ressortir cette identité cette double
culture
le dernier projet que je viens de
terminer je suis en train de terminer
c'est un album de chanson des chansons à
texte en français et je suis allé
l'enregistrer à Tahiti
parce que pour moi
c'était
comme une évidence j'avais envie de
partager les sons qui me sont chers les
sons de mon enfance les percussions à
bois les cœurs traditionnels j'ai fait
se rencontrer ce mélange et j'en suis
hyper fière aujourd'hui et c'est un
projet libérateur pour moi
pendant des années
25 ans je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
ça prend du temps je me suis demandé
qui j'étais en commençant mon parcours
sous les projecteurs en tant que Miss
France où on perd un peu son identité on
sait plus vraiment qui on est on est une
image
je me suis dit mais
est-ce que je suis la fille à paillette
est-ce que je suis la fille des pieds
nus
est-ce que je suis la fille sous les
projecteurs
est-ce que je suis la fille sous le
soleil
ça m'a pris du temps
mais aujourd'hui en tout cas je le sais
et je peux l'affirmer je suis une fille
à paillettes les pieds nus sous les
projecteurs qui aiment être sous le
soleil voilà qui je suis devenu
mais tout ça pour dire
que même si vous avez une autre culture
même si vous venez d'ailleurs
servez-vous de vos souvenirs qu'ils
soient bon ou qu'il soit mauvais
servez-vous de vos origines
de votre différence ma différence
a toujours fait ma force
donc peu importe
d'où vous venez peu importe vos
souvenirs servez-vous-en ça vous aidera
toujours à être plus créatif plus
combatif plus fort et si je peux me
permettre de donner un conseil ce soir
c'est rester vous-même
profondément vous-même
et résolument vous même merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]